this is the us-made Patriot air defense
system since two were delivered to
Ukraine in April it's proving to be an
indispensable tool in kiev's arsenal
that's because the system is defending
Ukraine's ground troops cities and
critical infrastructure amid a barrage
of Russian attacks
so why does the Patriot have an
advantage over other air defense systems
let's break it down
at the start of the war Ukraine relied
on a stockpile of soviet-era Defense
systems those weapons can Target slower
moving aerial targets such as drones and
cruise missiles but they have struggled
to combat faster moving ballistic
missiles now Patriot systems are helping
Ukrainian forces to intercept those
projectiles that's according to a
Ukrainian air defense Commander
interviewed by The Wall Street Journal
ism
consists of multiple components three of
its main parts sit on top of truck
platforms
the radar tracks missiles and other
targets it can detect aircraft up to 62
miles away and ballistic missiles more
than 100 miles away it sends data to the
engagement control station that unit
then processes the information before
sending it to the launching station
which can carry up to 16 missiles
foreign
military analysts say the system has
outperformed initial expectations in
Ukraine is
also known as the kinzal the kh-47 is
one of Russia's most advanced weapons
on May 16th a patriot detected six
Russian kins are ballistic missiles at a
distance of around 125 miles the system
launched interceptors destroying all of
them Patriots in Ukraine fire at Targets
using two different types of
interceptors Pack 2 and pack three pack
two downs targets through blast
fragmentation and Pack 3 uses hit to
kill technology instead by combining the
Patriot with other air defense systems
Ukraine is now fending off most aerial
threats against
however the Patriot does have some
disadvantages it's by far the most
expensive single weapon system that the
US has supplied to Ukraine each Patriot
system costs around one billion dollars
and takes two years to build
the missiles fired out of the Patriot
are expensive too
each pack 3 costs around 4.1 million
dollars the high cost per missile and
the relatively small number of missiles
in a battery means that Patriot
operators cannot shoot at every Target
in addition the Patriot requires a lot
of Manpower the systems need as many as
90 soldiers to operate but the control
station can be operated in the field by
as few as three
gaining more batteries could help Kiev
in a number of ways amid the
counter-offensive namely being able to
protect ground troops from aerial
threats as they push to retake territory
this sum up the U.S announced a new
military package worth up to 500 million
dollars
the aid will include ammunition for
Patriot systems according to a statement
from the Pentagon
there are at least two full Patriot
systems operating in Ukraine
in July Germany announced it would
provide two additional Patriot missile
launchers
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has said the country wants as many as
50.